PROFESSOR: OK, its always
disappointing when, just as
you're ready to tie everything
up in a nice, neat little
package and leave the room to a
round of applause, you screw
up the last little detail.
Anyway, what's wrong here is,
I said for an arbitrary
rotation around X3, and I'm
comforted only by the fact
that nobody else caught this
little glitch either, the
answer elements are a11, a11,
a33, a12, not 0, and
-a12, 0, 0, 0, 0.
So there's a skew-symmetric
form when there's just a
single rotation axis.
So this would be asymmetry n
and this would be one of a
family of two different
symmetries, the dihedral
groups n22, the two-fold axes
would require that these be
equal, so, 0, 0, 0,
a11, 0, 0, 0, a33.
So this is not the form of the
tensor for a four-fold axis,
it's the form for a crystal
with symmetry 422.
And same for a three-fold
axis.
This is the form
for 32 and 622.
For just the single rotation
axis of any sort other than 2,
these two terms are equal
in magnitude, but non-0.
Now if you look at the equation
for the tensor, the
term in a12, x1, x2, and a21,
x1, x2 are opposite in sign
and disappear.
So the quadric is, in fact
a surface of revolution
So the question is why are there
two degrees of freedom
rather than three?
And I think the answer to that
is going to lie in what is
required of the eigenvectors
when the off diagonal turns
are skew-symmetric, and that is
something I've not thought
about before.
All right, so that one minor
loose end sticking out of the
lid as we try to close the box
on this segment of our
discussion.
I'd like t move on to
a different set of
considerations.
One of the things that we can
subject a crystal to as a
generalized force is not merely
a vector force, but
stimulations that are
more complicated.
And I would like to in
particular now, as a prelude
to get into getting
into property
tensors of higher rank.
I'd like to . first discuss
stress, and then define
strain, and you've all
heard of these
questions in other contexts.
I'm going to introduce it,
though, in terms of the tensor
notation that we've used for
other sorts of tensors, just
so that we have everything in
terms of the same language.
So let me introduce stress by
supposing I have a volume
element in a solid, and it will
not surprise you that I'm
going to define the coordinate
system in the solid by three
axes, X1, X2, X3
in a Cartesian.
system, and I will look at a
surface on the exterior of the
solid that cuts axis X1 at A,
axis X2 at B, and axis X3 at
C.
Then I'll assume that I have a
force density, force per unit
area applied to the surface.
And if this is force
per unit area, why
don't I call it a pressure?
Well, a special case of what
we normally think of as a
pressure is a hydrostatic
pressure, and that is
something that's always exactly
normal to the surface.
So I don't want to call it a
pressure to mislead you into
the assumption that this force
per unit area, which is a
vector, has to be normal
to the surface.
So I'll call it a force density,
which becomes a
hydrostatic pressure when
that force vector is
normal to the surface.
And I'll call that force density
vector K, and it will
have three components, KI.
Now, the solid is in
equilibrium, I will assume.
And if that external force is
not balance on the other side
by balancing forced, the volume
element in the solid
would undergo a linear
acceleration, or an angular
acceleration at the
very least.
So I will assume that this
force on the outside, KI,
which is a force
per unit area.
So to make that a force, I will
have to multiply that
force density by the
area of the surface
ABC, on which it acts.
And I'll say that this has to
be balanced for each of the
three directions, X1 and X2
and X3 by a force per unit
area acting on these
internal surfaces.
So I'll assume that there is
a force acting in the x1
direction, and I'll call
those a sigma IJ.
And I'll say that there's a
first force acting in the X1
direction on--
now I need to somehow specify
the orientation to the
surface, because on this
internal surface there's also
a force acting in
this direction.
Now on this back surface there's
also a force acting in
this direction.
So the forces acting on all
three internal surfaces in the
X1 direction have to balance
exactly the X1 direction, the
X1 component of the
force density.
So let me turn this to K1, and
I'll say this has to be a
force per unit area
acting on area.
First of all, I'll call the
origin O on area AOC.
Plus a force acting in the
X1 direction on area A--
whoops, what did I do?
I wanted to do this first
on area BOC, excuse me.
And a force in the X1 direction
acting on area AOC.
And finally a force acting
on area AOB.
And these are all acting in the
X1 direction, and I now
would like to introduce some
notation that indicates the
direction of the direction
orientation of the surface on
which that force acts.
And I will use the normal to
these internal surfaces to
define that.
So the force per unit area on
area AOB, that is a surface
whose normal is X3.
And I will call this
component sigma 13.
And I'll call this one area
AOC is normal to X2.
That's why I did that little
sleight of hand as I began
this, and finally area BOC
has as its normal X1.
So my use of subscripts here is
that this first subscript
is the direction in which
the force acts.
And the second subscript
will be the normal to
the internal surface.
So I've set up algebraically
a system of
subscripts that works.
We'll see that these
have some physical
significance in just a moment.
So what will I call these?
Well, let me get this in a
slightly different form.
Let me take the left hand side
and divide area ABC into all
of these other areas.
So this then will have
sigma 11 times area
BOC over area ABC.
And not surprisingly, sigma 12
will then have multiplying it
a term area AOC divided
by area ABC.
And this is all looking very
cumbersome, but you'll be
amazed at how this cleans
up in just a moment.
And this will be area AOB
over finally area AOC.
ABC again.
OK, so how can we
tidy this up?
Well, let me imagine that I have
some surface, a planar
surface, and its normal points
in this direction.
And I'm going to take that
area and project it onto
another surface whose normal
points in this direction.
And let's suppose that the
angle between these two
directions is phi, and
the angle between the
two surfaces is phi.
The area of this original
surface is A, and its normal
points in this direction.
And I project it onto a surface
whose normal is an
angle phi away.
This new area, A prime
is equal to A times
the cosine of phi.
So if we accept that, then the
first line of this equation,
which will be eventually a set
of three equations, this is
the ratio of area BOC over area
ABC, and what is that?
That is the angle between the
direction of the force density
and area ABC.
And here is area ABC.
That's the normal here.
And the first term involves
area BOC, and that is the
direction of X, the normal to
that is X1, and therefore the
ratio of these two areas is the
same thing as the cosine
of the angle between K and X1.
And this second ratio of areas
is going to be sigma 12 times
the cosine of the angle between
the force density
vector K and X2.
And the third term is going to
be sigma 13 times the cosine
of the angle between K and X3.
What these cosines are are just
the cosines of the angle
between K and the
three reference
axes, X1, X2, and X3.
So this is simply the direction
cosine L1 of K. And
this is the direction cosine
L2 of K. And this is the
direction cosine L3.
So the X1 component of the force
density vector is going
to be equal to a term sigma 11
times L1, plus the term sigma
12 times L2, the term
sigma 13 L3.
And if I would write down
similar balances, forces for
the X2 component of the force
density vector, not
surprisingly these things are
going to give me coefficients
that I'll label sigma 121, sigma
22 times L2, plus sigma
23 times L3.
And in general then the
requirement that this body be
in equilibrium states that each
component of the force
density vector should be given
by a coefficient sigma IJ
times L sub J. These are the
components of the force
density vector.
This is the direction cosines
of the direction of K.
This is a unit vector in the
direction of K. This is the
direction of a vector.
These are the components of
K. And therefore these
coefficients sigma IJ relate to
vectors, and they must be a
second rank tensor.
And these are called, as you
all know, it comes as no
surprise as the components
of stress.
So the reason that these are
really tensors, and not just a
vector force per unit area
essentially comes down to the
fact that the behavior of the
body, dynamically and
mechanically, is going to
depend not only on the
direction of the force, but on
the direction of the surface
on which it acts.
Quite clear here, if I shove,
is a force density,
and that's a vector.
But the way in which this desk
responds to my pushing on it
with a force vector of that
magnitude is going to depend
whether I do this, which is
going to compress it, or
whether it takes the same force
and direct it this way,
which if I don't move
the thing is going
to result in a shear.
So the behavior of the body will
depend on the direction
of the force per unit area
that I apply, and the
direction of the surface
on which I apply it.
In this case, that would
be the surface ABC.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: You say that the force
density is not parallel
to the normal of the surface?
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: So when you do the
ratio of [INAUDIBLE]
isn't it supposed to
be [INAUDIBLE]
of the normal to the
[INAUDIBLE] and X1?
PROFESSOR: Another way
of defining it.
This is a vector, and what I'm
doing is splitting that vector
up into three internal forces
that act on surfaces whose
normal are here.
So actually, what I'm going to
do is to take the way in which
the internal force
pushes back.
I see, that's what's
confusing.
If the force that I'm putting on
the body, I didn't mean to
indicate any particular
direction, but if this
component of K points in this
direction, this force that
balances it has to go in
the opposite direction.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying that
there were surface ABC is
defined as normal to K?
PROFESSOR: ABC is not normal.
No.
ABC is not normal to K. All I'm
saying is that it if it
were normal to K, then the
balancing force would be just
a function of this orientation
of the surface.
But if I allow this to be a
general force per unit area,
then the balancing force on
the inside depends on the
angle between K and the angle
between this internal surface.
AUDIENCE: I don't see the
relation between K and the
ratio between other ends.
BOC and ABC [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
The reason that there are three
areas, is that what's
troubling you?
Because I'm really now splitting
the balancing force
up into a force per unit area
on this surface, and a force
per unit area on this surface,
and a force per unit area on
this surface.
And that's so that I can look at
these different components
of resistance in terms of
a Cartesian system.
Clear that the ratio of these
two areas does go as the--
I erased it now, that is
going to go as the--
This is A prime, and this is the
original A, the relation
between those areas is
given by the cosine
of this angle phi.
If I [INAUDIBLE] this down in
this projection, and this is
the area of A.
This is the direction of the
normal to the surface ABC.
And I'm going to let this be the
direction of the normal to
one of the internal surfaces,
and these internal surfaces
are going to have as their
normal either X1, X2, or X3.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
between the normal
to ABC and X1.
PROFESSOR: And X1, yes.
And that's what I'm saying its,
and that is going to be
the same thing.
As the cosine of that angle is
just going to be the direction
cosine of the normal to ABC
relative to X1, X2, X3.
OK?
AUDIENCE: So in the end,
you're saying that K is
parallel to the normal of ABC?
PROFESSOR: No, I'm not.
No, I'm not.
This is a relation between
the areas.
And these are the
forces acting on
those internal surfaces.
And I'm saying there are three
of them, and those three
components that are all acting
in the X1 direction will
depend on the ratio
of these areas.
The ratio of this area is
the cosine of the angle
between X1 and K. OK.
This you're OK with?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And what I'm saying now is that
there is acting on this
internal surface something
that has to balance the
component of K, which points
in the direction of X1.
And the component of K before
we divided out the area, the
component of K1 times the area
gave me the net force.
So this K1 now is a force per
unit area, the component of K
per unit area that points
along the X1 direction.
Now as a force per unit area I
multiply it by an area that
gave me force.
There are three forces
internally that balance this
force, and they all act
in the X1 direction.
AUDIENCE: You're just
[INAUDIBLE].
Shouldn't it be the cosine of
the angle between the normals
of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's what I'm saying here.
That for X, for this surface,
yeah, that's what I'm saying.
One of these surfaces here, if
we look at the first term,
this is the direction of X1, and
the force here will be the
force along K. And if I take
this force and put it down in
X1, this is going to be
the force times the
cosine of the angle.
And the two areas are going to
go as the cosine of the angle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
cosine of the normal
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
This is indeed the ratio between
the internal area and
the external area.
Since the internal area has a
normal that's either X1, X2,
or X3 the angle between the
normal to these internal
surfaces and K is going to be
the direction cosine of K.
I suggest since we're getting
out of time quickly we either
resolve this after the
end of class or leave
it until next time.
That's a bad note on
which to end, too.
The point I want to leave, still
subject to resolution
and debate is that the
coefficient sigma IJ I would
like to claim relate
to vectors.
One is the direction of the
external surface, and if it
relates to vectors, then this
set of coefficients qualifies
as a second rank tensor.
And if you accept that, however
grudgingly, everything
that we've said about second
rank tensors holds for the
quantity sigma IJ, which are
called the elements of stress.
In particular, we can talk
about a stress quadrant.
We can talk about the
value of a stress in
a particular direction.
If we have a stress tensor in
which show all the terms are
non-0, it can be diagonalized.
We can also say that if the
crystal has symmetry, for
example, if the crystal is
cubic, you can say that the
form of a second rank
tensor for a cubic
crystal has to be diagonal.
And these diagonal elements
represent compressive
stresses, so you can say that
you can only subject a cubic
crystal to compressive stress.
On the other hand, if the
crystal is a triclinic
crystal, you can say that
there's a sigma 11, there's a
sigma 12, a sigma 13, a sigma
21, a sigma 22, sigma 23,
sigma 31, sigma 32, sigma 33.
So for a triclinic crystal,
there appear to be nine
elements, but next time we will
show that the nature of
stress is the body has to be in
equilibrium requires that
the stress tensor be by
definition symmetric if
there's to be no net couple
to force on it.
Going to buy this?
You didn't buy the things that
I said that perhaps were
slightly incorrect.
This is massively incorrect.
Jason?
AUDIENCE: You can rotate a cubic
crystal [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No.
Because say a tensor
of this form acts
just like the scalar.
Just like a cubic crystal, you
don't suddenly get off
diagonal properties
if you transfer it
to a different axis.
So unless you tell me what's
wrong here, I'm going to leave
this on your plate
until next week.
And I don't want you fretting
over the weekend.
This is clearly nonsense, and
it is a contradiction that
arises only if you carry too
much of what we've been doing
for the last month with you into
a discussion of stress
and strain.
Stress is something that you
impose on a crystal.
It has nothing to do with what
kind of crystal it is and
what's going on in the interior
of the crystal.
There may be constraints on the
coefficients that relate
stress and strains, and
there surely are.
But I can take a cubic crystal,
and I can squeeze it,
and I can twist it and share
it anyway I like.
So this is an important
distinction between the
tensors that represent physical
properties, which
we've been discussing
up to this point.
And the properties such as
conductivity, diffusivity,
susceptibility and so on and
all their many varieties,
these are something
which we'll refer
to as property tensors.
And they are tensors
demonstrably, but they are
tensors which describe
the physical
behavior of a crystal.
Nye uses a term that I don't
think is self explanatory, so
I don't care for it.
He calls these field tensors.
That sounds like some
description of a corn patch
that requires a tensor.
But no.
We probably don't really
think of what we mean
when we say a field.
When we say an electric field,
you think of an e-vector.
You think of a vector.
But what a field is is just a
set of coordinates, XYZ, and
that describes an area
or a volume.
And just like the things that
corn grow in are referred to
as corn fields, it's an area
that has corn on a lattice
very often also.
So a field is just a set of
coordinates in space to which
a value of something
is a sign.
So if we have an electric field,
and we express that
electric field as a function
of X, Y, and Z, that is a
field of vectors.
If we take something that
has intrinsically, that
intrinsically needs to be
described as a tensor, then we
have to every point in space XYZ
a tensor sigma IJ, whose
value and whose components
value vary with position
within the space.
So talking about the field as
assigning values of something
to every coordinate in the space
that could be a tensor.
What we refer to as an electric
field really is a
field vector.
So that's Nye's term, but the
fact that it took me three
minutes to explain why he uses
it explains as well why I
don't care for it.
So we'll talk about these
as property tensors.
And property tensors are
something that's
innate to the material.
Something like stress, strain,
and other second rank tensors
are external stimuli, just
like an electric field.
And they have value that is
imposed on the crystal, and
the stress field is defined
as a function of position.
So that's the distinction
between a property tensor,
which is subject to symmetry
constraints, and a tensor that
represents a stimulus, an
external stimulus applied to
the crystal, and it's defined
as a function of position.
And that is a field tensor.
OK, so that's the difference.
Since this is something that's
imposed externally, it can
have any form of the tensor
that you wish to oppose.
And there are no symmetry
restrictions on it.
The only restriction is, as
we'll show next time, that it
must be symmetric if the body
is to be in equilibrium.
All right.
It is time to quit, and
that I think is a good
place to leave things.
And we'll say more about
stress next time.